salut c'est monsieur heureux aujourd'hui
on a parlé du samsung galaxy x
on en a beaucoup parlé c'est un
smartphone qui va arriver très
prochainement et on a plusieurs infos on
a trois infos la première c'est sa date
de sortie
la deuxième c'est la taille de son écran
et la troisième c'est son prix et je
vais tout vous dire
le samsung galaxy x est un petit peu
l'arlésienne on en parle depuis 2011
depuis que samsung nx lorquin travailler
sur un smartphone avec un écran pliable
c'est vraiment un truc qui pourrait
changer la face des smartphones on voit
qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'évolutions pendant des années on eu
des petites évolutions tranquillement
voilà des design qui change un peu des
bordeaux qui prennent un peu plus grand
des coteaux un peu plus grand là on voit
qu'il se passe quand même pas mal de
choses avec le niveau d'aix on a vu
l'arrivée d'un smartphone pour coup sans
rien c'est juste en écran sur la face
avant et ça c'est super joli est là avec
ses smartphones et des écrans pliables
qui vont arriver dès l'année prochaine
on devrait y arriver dans toute chose
une petite révolution voir une grande
révolution ça pourrait être super
intéressant c'est pas dit que samsung
soit le premier à dégainer là dessus il
se pourrait qu'un autre concurrent
arrive en premier mais en attendant
samsung risque d'arriver avec un produit
fini extrêmement beau extrêmement bien
réussi c'est juste cool l'info de la
taille de l'écran nous vient de kim lui
en jambes viol
je suis désolé kim j'ai beaucoup de mal
à prononcer donc je veux dire kim jong
violent qui est responsable de la
recherche pour golden bridge
investissment elles veulent un décor
simple tous les maux qui a confirmé
certaines fuites c'est à dire qu'il
aurait un écran oled de 7,3 pouces qui
une fois refermée aurait un écran de 4.5
pouces ça c'est pour l'intérieur il ya
vous allez avoir un grand écran de 7,3
pouces et lorsque vous allez replier
vous allez voir l'écran de 4 d'haguenau
5 pouces d'un côté et de l'autre du oled
donc un contraste infini des couleurs
qui ressorte énormément vraiment un très
bel écran on connaît la qualité des
écrans de samsung avec les écrans
infiniti on sait que ça me saoule avec
des écrans qui sont vraiment super beau
et là on imagine un écran de 5,3 pouces
quelque chose avec un énorme format et
une fois à fermer format pocket glisser
dans votre poche alors il aurait trois
écrans parce que vous me direz que
lorsque des lavoirs un très grand écran
comme ça exact le refermer vous n'avez
plus rien à voir donc savoir qui vous
appelle quel message avez reçu à moins
d'avoir une montre connectés sinon c'est
tout rapidement mettez donc vous allez
avoir sur la façade en un autre écran
qui permettra d'avoir les informations
courantes et notifications quelque chose
comme ça donc ça c'est cool
en plus de ça ça me saoule pas racheter
une technologie qui s'appelle la
technologie muscles artificiels
je sais c'est peut-être un terme qui est
traduit qui du coup en français est un
petit peu vridi
le muscle artificiel en attendant cette
techno l'as intéressante parce qu'elle
va permettre aux composants qui sont à
l'intérieur de bouger en même temps que
l'écran sans risquer de les endommager
donc vous avez votre muscle artificiel
je vais prendre votre smartphone vous
étiez grâce aux hits artificielle tout
va bouger sans risque d'altération donc
ça autre point positif on a une info
maintenant qui nous vient de co john
jean qui est président de la division
téléphonie mobile de samsung qui a
confirmé la conception de l'appareil et
qui a aussi dit qu'ils étaient en train
de définir une date de sortie donc on
est extrêmement traits d'une date de
sortie pour ce samsung galaxy s donc
tenez vous prêts on est une info qui
nous vient du porte parole de samsung
qui s'appelle kim choong gone gone
pardon qu'il s'appelle clip qui assure
que le développement de l'appareil avec
un vrai écran pliable suit son cours on
voit qu'on n'a jamais été aussi près de
la sortie cet appareil donc ça c'est
plutôt une bonne nouvelle concernant la
date de sortie
là on a fini un petit peu les infos ça
nous vient de l'analyste de xi'an
finances jan s'appelle park jung moo
faute plus désolé parc pour avoir
écorché ton nom qui a confirmé je le
cite nos fournisseurs et sous traitants
commenceront à livrer les pièces et les
composants la division des smartphones
de samsung electronics
début novembre début novembre c'est
presque demain
ça veut dire que le produit est
quasiment terminée et reste plus
maintenant qu'à trouver des
distributeurs et le passé en phase de
commercialisation
à ce sujet ils ont annoncé que les
prototypes seront présentés aux
opérateurs mobiles aux 6es à las vegas
début 2010
ça c'est cool d'autant plus que le csj
serait alors je serais pas du tout dans
les salons où les prototypes se présente
néanmoins je serai donc moins facile
d'aller un peu renifler tendance à tirer
d'abord un peu ce qui se passe en tout
cas c'est une bonne nouvelle parce qu'on
voit que dès lors que les proto vont
être présentés aux opérateurs début
janvier cela signifie que le smartphone
est prêt le smartphone va être
commercialisé donc on imagine qu'en
présentant aux opérateurs début janvier
on va dire qu'il pourrait présenter au
grand public en février en mars
ça veut dire que début 2019 on devrait
voir arriver enfin enfin j'en ai dire il
pas trop tard sur ce marché ce samsung
galaxy x d'ailleurs une question je vous
pose est ce que vous pourriez acheter ce
produit je vous ai pas encore parlé du
prix ça va arriver d'ici quelques temps
mais est-ce que sur le papier ce produit
vous le trouvez séduisant est-ce que
vous pourrez vous laisser tenter est ce
qu'un écran de 5,3 pouces pliable en 4,5
pouces est ce que vous pourriez lâcheté
est ce que ça pourrait vous intéresser
est ce que pour vous ça a un sens
marc coma tous sans commentaire alors
maintenant quand on est ému prix c'est
toujours notre amie kim kim kyong sol
qui est toujours responsable de la
recherche pour golden bridge investments
qui a annoncé le tarif
alors accrochez vous tenez vous avez
vous déjà vous donner le tarif en one un
qui serait de 2 millions moines jusque
là je suppose que ça ne vous dit rien
fectivement 2 millions ça fait peur on
pourrait dire je n'ai pas acheté un
smartphone 2 millions se sont ni des
dollars ni d euros ni des francis niss
que vous voulez donc un rester
tranquille ça représente la somme de
1500 75 euros hors taxes hors taxes hors
tva
je suppose qu'à aussi des frais de
douane bon mais en tout cas considérer
la tva pour la france c'est 20%
ça dépend après du pays dans lequel vous
vous situez on proclame le smartphone
qui est quand même relativement cher on
est quasiment à 1600 euros hors taxes le
produit donc ça veut dire que pour
acheter le smartphone le plus innovantes
du moment avec les nouvelles techno avec
un muscle artificiel avec un écran
pliable de 16,3 pause qui passe fermée
en cas de gain de 5 pouces il va falloir
claque un peu votre portefeuille
on parle de 1600 euros hors taxes on va
probablement parlé de quasiment
problème les 2000 euros ttc livré chez
vous ça va faire mal qu'un impôt
portefeuille malgré tout malgré ce prix
est ce que vous pourriez vous laisser
tenter ce que au final
au final l'idée de ce smartphone elle
vous tente est ce que l'idée d'avoir un
smartphone avec un écran pliable ça vous
tente parce que on en parle beaucoup
sans lâcher parce que je trouve que
c'est super intéressant que ça permet un
petit peu de voir ce qui va arriver dans
les temps à venir en terme de
technologie il est évident que le
smartphone classique comme on le connaît
actuellement c'est-à-dire un des trucs
un peu comme ça que vous ayez un écran
borderless un grand écran pas de haut
parleurs où je peux vous voulez ça reste
néanmoins une forme un petit peu plus
conventionnel c'est un smartphone qui ne
se plient pas si j'essaie d'oublier
je vais évidemment complètement le
fracasser donc je vais complètement
inutile de le faire est ce que le fait a
contrario d'avoir des écrans pliables ça
pourrait vous intéresser ce que pour
vous c'est un sens parce que pour moi
c'en est un vrai temps déjà les
capacités des industriels à se
renouveler et achètent toujours avoir
des produits qui correspondent toujours
plus à nos besoins on voit que des
écrans augmente donc voulu avoir une
tablette du si dans votre poche moins
d'avoir des énormes baggy pour pouvoir
glisser votre tablette
sinon rien moment cette course folle aux
écrans toujours plus grands pas
s'arrêter parce que vous êtes à pouvoir
les loger et les emmener partout avec
vous donc à un moment donné j'ai passé
sur la miniaturisation des écrans qui se
plie ça a un sens alors qu on pourrait
imaginer plus tard quelques années des
projections holographiques ou je ne sais
quoi on n'y est pas encore là c'est
encore très très loin mais je voudrais
encore imaginent d'autres solutions
parce qu'à un moment les consommations
parce que les envies et les besoins vont
encore changer ou encore du moins évolué
donc là pour le coup un écran pliable ça
un vrai sens pour avoir un vrai gain
imaginez vous avez un écran de 7,3
pousse ses dires du 3 pouces ça vous
fait mal et ça fait une tablette est ce
que ça vous intéresserait d'avoir un
smartphone qui est un d'écran hyper
confortable sur lequel si vous arrivez à
un âge avancé ne faisait pas besoin de
mettre des grands lunettes parce que
vous avez un bon caractère en énorme
dessus pourquoi pas mais sinon vous
allez quand même vous pouvoir profiter
d'avoir plus d'applications un vrai
multitâche un vrai outil de travail un
vrai outil ludique avec un superbe écran
donc ça s'appelle vraiment intéressant
dites moi ce que vous en pensez en
commentaire parce que je trouve que
vraiment c'est super intéressant
donc voilà un peu les infos qu'on a
aujourd'hui la date de sortie c'est
début 2019
une présentation aux opérateurs mobiles
en janvier au cel dont une sortie
publique on peut compter février
mars pour avoir vraiment quelque chose
d'assez cohérent un tarif aux alentours
des 1600 euros hors taxes un écran de
5,3 pouces ouvert 4,5 pouces permet
trois écrans en réalité deux écrans un
grand écran en intérieur et en écrans
extérieurs voilà un peu pour ces infos
aujourd'hui sur le samsung galaxy ips
j'attends tout vos commentaires et
réactions tout sujet tout ce que vous
voulez directement en bas en
commentaires disent ils avaient témoin
des jolies pousse des lags de l'amour
abonnez vous vous allez voir on va déjà
les hausses et baisses l'année prochaine
donc on n'y est pas encore on encore un
petit peu de temps mais on va aller au
sommet donc comme ça je vous emmènerai
avec moi dans les bagages on allait voir
un petit peu ce qui se passe s'ils
renient fut un peu les tendances dans
les nouveaux produits avant le cs on va
partir à l'ifa à berlin d'ici quelques
temps on a essayé de se bouger un peu la
droite à gauche on a aussi partir très
très très prochainement au mois de
juillet pour une grande marque
je ne vous dis rien je garde le secret
vous emmènerai également avec moi dans
mon sac à dos pour aller faire un petit
peu le tour du monde au club est
connecté à très bientôt des finales chez
moi dépose des bizots vos commentaires
et bientôt 12 ans
[Musique]